but it had one tip that i think is gold
like this is a million dollar tip so
for anyone who's watching this i
guarantee you this will improve your
writing
how can one word in a story be so
powerful can make or break a sentence
wow um i don't know about one word but i
do think that um
word choice obviously can really color
you know how a scene flows and this
probably isn't what you're getting at
but
this this is an example of something
that really surprised me
you know i always feel like most of my
leaps in writing quality
come from writing something else you
know so for example
many many long time ago i was uh
i had a i was writing a screenplay
and i had a book that i was reading
about writing novels because i was
always trying to write a novel you know
sort of in the background of everything
and i don't even think this was a
particularly good book about writing
novels but it had one tip
that i think is gold like this is a
million dollar tip so
for anyone who's watching this i
guarantee you this will improve your
writing
and it's the tip was when you're
finished with a manuscript
do a word search for ly
because most adverbs end in l y and
adverbs
are usually imprecise and are not the
best word for what you're trying to
convey
and i was like wow like that really
stood out to me and so i took my script
that i was working on
i'll try it on my script and i tried it
on my script and sure enough when i
finished i was like this is better you
know like it really made it better
so i mean i think i think a lot of times
when you're writing
you know your first draft you're kind of
just trying to get it down but if you
can go back and say what was i really
trying to say there you know and if
you're using words like
he walked slowly to the door like well
is that really what you mean or do you
mean he
stalked towards the door or he crept
towards the door you know or he sneaked
towards the door and
you know if you know i don't think
always that applies but a lot of times i
think you'll find that
you were really trying to say something
else a little more specific and by
getting rid of that
adverb and finding the the right word
it's going to make the scene
pop you know in the reader's head it
makes it much more visual because you
can envision someone
sneaking but if you envision someone
walking slowly you might not see the
same thing
you know and i think that really helped
my writing oh that was just one of those
little like aha moments that i
always remember even though it was you
know like probably 20 years ago
what's the male version of the mary sue
oh there's a name for that um so i
thought
i can't remember what they call it but
there is a male name for it yeah the
character who's just perfect
like who never fails and never i think
really what
i don't even think it's the fact that
they're perfect i think it's that they
never have to struggle
i think that's what people don't like
you know we don't want
and that's i think why it goes back to
what i said before about escalating
action you know we don't want
our heroes to resolve things easily you
know we want them to struggle we want
them to fight you know we want
we want us we want them to show the
strength that we wish we had or that we
believe that we have you know that
and and when things just come easy
that's not a
interesting story you know right so
with your novels it seems like from the
get-go you're establishing that this
character is
not a mary sue no yeah kane i mean i
guess it depends on
of course he's the hero so of course he
tends to win but i always put him
through the ringer you know like i mean
he gets hurt he gets beat up he gets you
know cut and
shot and you know by the end he you know
could a person who went through all that
really win at the end maybe not that's
where i think fiction comes in and we're
we'll suspend our disbelief um
you know when i was growing up uh the
two two of the big action heroes
in the box office were uh jean-claude
van damme and steven seagal
and i always liked jean-claude van damme
better because steven seagal
never took a hit in his movies he just
went through and wiped the floor with
everybody no one touched him
but van damme would always get beat up
you know or he's like crucified on a
pole
or you know something and at the end he
rises up and he wins like
to me that's the story i want to see
that's great
i like that that's pretty funny
that's true you're right it just pushes
him out of the way and
he never gets dirty yeah he never gets
he never gets touched like his hair is
always perfect
yeah exactly because that is the martial
he does aikido which is all about
redirecting attacks but i
for me as a hero i never i just couldn't
i didn't like him you know it
bothered me what's your work schedule
like when you're writing
like i said i i'm usually i used to
write start writing a little earlier i
think
i think i used to start writing around 8
or 8 30. now i usually
start by 9 30 is what i tried to do but
i still try to keep it
like kind of half business hours you
know i mean so basically i try to start
when i would start a normal job
and i write till about lunch you know
somewhere around there
and then after lunch i may still write
but it'll be other things you know so
so the book i'm working on will be the
first thing that i tackle
and i'll write that to about lunch and
then after lunch if i have other things
i'm working on like a screenplay
or copy or even stuff from my own
business like advertising
or email newsletters things like that
that's when i'll work on the other stuff
in the afternoon
and you take weekends off yes is that
something you've ever
been tempted to say ah why don't i do
something all the time but my fiance
gets very unhappy when i when i do that
uh sometimes like if i'm almost about to
finish i'll be like look
baby i just gotta finish this book and
she understands but um you know for the
most part
i i try to devote the weekends to other
things and i think it's good to let your
brain recharge you know
before you dive back in have you noticed
that then when you're
at the point where you have to finish
and it's seven days a week
that you feel like some of your
creativity is dwindling
not really because usually when i get to
the end
you get you get this big kind of burst
of excitement and momentum you're like
oh my god i'm done you know it's almost
done like i can just see the ending one
more chapter
so usually that's when i will work on
weekends and that kind of carries me
through certainly
i think if i tried to do that all
throughout the book absolutely i would
get burned out
i think it's good to have breaks and to
let your brain kind of think ahead you
know
but when i do do it it's usually very
kind of exciting you know it's like the
final stretch have you always loved
every character you've created
well i mean i i don't love
that's a tricky one i don't like you
have to
create characters that you you have to
understand your characters
i don't think you have to love them in
the sense that some of the characters
you write will
not be deserving of love i mean uh you
know i've written some horrific
villains but i always try to
give the villain a reason you know for
what they're doing um
most of my villains tend to have sort of
tragic backstories
because i think that i just think in the
real world that's
the way that's the way i see the world i
see suffering leads to more suffering
you know everyone kind of has their own
worldview and their own take on villains
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with a villain just being sort of bad
inherently bad but i do think that i
just find it more interesting if there's
a little bit of a reason why you know
they see the world the way they do
um so i don't know that
those characters i love them but i
understand them
how do you stay invested in a story if
your character is unlikable
or there's parts of them that's
unlikable
well i think if parts of them are
unlikable that's fine i mean there's
parts of
parts of everyone is unlikable right
nobody's perfect and
you know a story is about a person
struggling to overcome something right
so their flaws can be just as important
to that process as their strengths in
fact probably more so
because if they're put into something
that's playing perfectly to their
strengths then it's probably too easy
for them it's their flaws that make it
interesting
so i think the more you incorporate
those flaws and their weaknesses
or you know a big a big kind of ongoing
thing in the cane stories is one of his
problems is he can't trust anybody you
know and so sometimes
that actually causes him to make the
wrong decision because he's
so bitter and so cynical if he just
trusted his agency contact things would
go better but he can't because of what's
happened to him in the past you know
that makes it
more interesting and more dramatic um
and i think that makes it also easier to
stay
invested i think it would be harder to
stay invested in a story where
the hero is just sort of infallible and
you're always playing to their strengths
and they win every fight and overcome
every doubt i would have a really hard
time staying interested in
in writing you know as well as reading
can you give me some examples of how he
shows some of his weaknesses i know you
said sometimes he doesn't trust his
agency contact
well for instance so in the latest book
he um
he's kind of come in from the cold and
now he is working with the cia again
um because there's you know there's
someone that he actually does trust
is now in a position of power and
they've you know he's gone through this
whole process in the other books and now
he's working for the cia again
so they send him uh into vietnam to find
uh
this missing contact and they have a
someone to
they say you know we'll we've got a
contact for you to
to meet with to get some intel from and
they'll set you up with everything they
need but he refuses to
deal with that person because he's like
no i trust you but i don't trust
everyone else working
you know for the cia it's like i'll go
through my own contacts
and so he goes to sort of the shady
character that he knows
but that character ends up betraying him
because
they're a scumbag you know like and so
he kind of realizes if i had just
listened and you know trusted this
person like it would have gone way
better now he's jeopardized the mission
because he couldn't put his trust in his
superiors and so he has to kind of he's
kind of
working under the weight of that
knowledge that wow i almost screwed this
all up you know
so that's sort of that's the most recent
example i can think of
and why doesn't he trust actual people
within the agency but he
trusts some fringe character because
he really shouldn't i mean it's a
mistake but he because he has a history
of being betrayed
by people within the cia and because he
doesn't
he sees the work he did with the cia in
the past as
not really being noble you know he
realizes he was kind of used and
the things that he did weren't really
making the world a better place you know
in his opinion
so he just has this kind of wall of
anger and
guilt and really kind of self-loathing
in essence you know i mean it's i think
i think it's more about him being angry
at himself for being
fooled you know and that that when
you're angry at yourself you don't make
the best decisions you know and i think
that's
a case where i intentionally had him
make a bad decision you know i mean he
later regrets it and realizes that
wasn't the smart thing to do
you